Originally, of course, nobody knew what caused
the various forms of tuberculosis, and they
certainly didn’t understand it was caused
by what would eventually be called tubercle
bacillus (usually the offending microbes are
specifically Mycobacterium tuberculosis).
The word “tuberculosis” was coined by
Johann Lukas Schönle in 1839, from the Latin
“tuberculum,” meaning “small, swelling
bump or pimple.”
However, it wouldn’t be until 1882 when
Dr. Robert Koch discovered the tubercle bacillus,
for which he won a Nobel Prize in 1905, that
the name “tuberculosis” began being exclusively
used to refer to the disease formerly popularly
known as consumption.
The microbes that cause the disease have been
around for at least 15,000-20,000 years with
known human deaths being caused by the bacteria
dating back at least as far as 5,000 years
ago, so the current name is an extremely recent
moniker relative to how long the disease has
been around.
The much older name originally came from the
ancient Greeks who called the disease something
meaning “consumption,” “phthisis,”
specifically referring to pulmonary tuberculosis,
with the earliest references to this being
in 460 BC.
The “father of Western medicine,” Hippocrates,
estimated that phthisis was the most widespread
disease of his age.
He further told his students that they shouldn’t
attempt to treat patients in the last stages
of phthisis, as they were sure to die and
it would ruin his protégés’ reputation
as healers if they made a practice of attempting
to heal such individuals.
Tuberculosis wasn’t just found across the
pond either, but it is known to have been
present in the Americas as early as 100 AD.
So why was “phthisis” aka “consumption”
chosen for the name?
It was because the disease seemed to consume
the individual, with their weight drastically
dropping as the disease progressed.
Heroin was originally marketed by the drug
company Bayer as a safe, non-addicting treatment
for tuberculosis, among other things.